- Hey out there.
Welcome in.
Welcome to another
edition of Market Takes.
There's a lot going on this week
but here on Market Takes,
we're gonna tell you
the three most important things
that you need to be
watching out for this week.
One of them is the big Inflation report
we've got coming out on Thursday,
the CPI, Consumer Price Index.
Economists are expecting that to rise,
or Inflation to pick up,
increase from the previous
month for the first time
in about 13, going on a
little more than a year,
a little over 13 months.
That could be big
and we are gonna talk about
how the market could react.
We've also got some big earnings reports
from likes of Disney and UPS,
a number of other companies.
We're gonna tell you
which ones to hone in for
and what to look for in those reports.
And of course, you may
not have known this,
but the New York Fed Household
and Consumer Debt Report
is out this week as well as
the US Consumer Credit Report.
That's out a little later today.
Tell you what to look for and
why those will be important
for the market, for investors,
but also for you and I
regular folks out there.
So let's talk about it.
Listen, first report I want to talk about
is the CPI, Consumer Price Index,
that Inflation report that's
coming out on Thursday.
Wanna throw something
up here on your screen
just to give you an idea
of what we've been seeing.
So as you see, this chart goes back
to the beginning of 2022
and you see Inflation just steadily rising
and peaking in that 9% area, right?
In June, that was the
highest Inflation had been
in around 40 years, a
little more than 40 years.
June, 9.1% year over year Inflation.
And so compared to the previous year,
we have seen Inflation come
down every single month
since then into June.
And so now for that July report,
economists surveyed by Dow Jones
are expecting Inflation to
actually have increased to 3.3%.
Now, this is important because
it's going to counteract
if Inflation does behave as expected,
it's going to counter and move differently
than what we've seen for over a year.
And that could be a big shakeup
or a big surprise for the market.
Now, like I said, this is priced in,
economists expect 3.3% Inflation.
And remember, we're now comparing
to lower numbers than
what we were in June.
So that could be one reason
why Inflation picks up.
It may not be a big reason
for concern or worry
but you're gonna wanna look
inside the details of the report.
Now, is this about Goods or Services?
We've seen Goods prices
consistently falling
and Services prices picking up.
How much does that happen and
how much does that continue?
But we are expecting to see
a change in this pattern
that we've seen for a number of months,
and it's going to be a question
of how the market deals with that.
But this chart here,
just illustrating the way
that Inflation has
behaved over the past year
and economists are
expecting that we will see
that kind of reverse and
Inflation pick back up.
How much it picks up, why it picks up,
what moves it higher, and why
are going to be closely watched.
You're gonna want to
tune into Market Takes.
We'll be right here, 10:00 AM
Eastern on Thursday morning
to break all that down
for you and talk about
how it relates to the Federal Reserve
and what they're planning
and what they're gonna do
going forward through
the rest of the year.
The Fed really is data dependent now,
the data is going to
drive their decisions.
So we will see how that
report really impacts
and influences that.
And it's gonna be all about
the details in that report
and we'll break all that down with you.
Like I said, Thursday morning,
10:00 AM right here on Market Takes.
How will the market react?
We're gonna find out
and we're gonna talk
through that together.
What we talk about next,
let's talk about Earnings,
UPS and Disney are the big
ones that are coming out
this week and they will
be out a little bit later
coming on on Tuesday and Wednesday.
So you're gonna wanna watch
for those out this week.
We also get Earnings reports from Alibaba.
I think you'll wanna watch that
because there has been this big story
about the slow down in the Chinese economy
and I think those Alibaba Earnings reports
because that's a company
that has to report Earnings.
They're required to put those numbers out
and we will really get
a real deal look inside
what's happening in China
from one of its biggest companies.
We'll get those reports.
Also, we get Lyft, Fox,
Buzzfeed, Coinbase, Palantir,
some others but I really
think UPS and Disney
are the two you're gonna wanna watch for.
Those are a couple
companies that have really,
their stocks have
underperformed year to date
and over the past year.
UPS is up only 3% year to
date compared to the 17% gain
in the overall S and P 500.
Over the past one year period it's down 8%
compared with an 8%
rise in the S and P 500.
That really has resulted from, again,
the slowdown in goods
that we've talked about.
Folks aren't buying as much,
they're not going as much through UPS
but there are also a number
of other issues for UPS.
We saw just today, the company Yellow,
one of the largest trucking
companies in the US.
In fact, I think the
largest trucking company,
risk applied for or filed for
bankruptcy protection today.
We have seen FedEx had weak Earnings.
So these numbers from UPS are
gonna be very highly watched,
considering where we are
right now in the economy.
It's gonna tell us about online shipping,
it's gonna tell us how
those lower fuel prices,
if that contributed to UPS's bottom line,
affected growth, summer
travel, all of those things,
UPS is gonna tell us a lot about.
Another company you're
gonna wanna watch, Disney,
down 3% year to date and down
21% over the past one year.
Those are gonna be watched,
not only for those Disney Plus numbers,
but you're also gonna wanna watch,
as we think about how much
Americans are traveling,
are they going back to
theme parks, Disneyland,
Disney World, all those
resorts that Disney owns,
things like that.
How much has Disney been able to benefit
from this big pickup and
travel that we have seen?
We hear that Americans are
spending, they're going out,
they're very confident,
they're spending their money.
Well, is Disney able to benefit from that
and are they attracting those people?
Is the economy still behaving as it was?
Those Earnings reports are gonna tell us
a lot about how much
they've bounced back or not.
So we'll see.
You're gonna wanna watch those.
Disney and UPS this week,
I think gonna tell us
a lot about the economy.
Last but not least, the
US consumer credit report
is out Monday afternoon,
that's today at 3:00 PM.
Check that out.
We've seen continually rising credit
as in more folks in the US
taking out debt, credit,
but we have seen it rising more
slowly and month over month
we've actually seen a
significant deceleration
in terms of credit.
I think that may have a lot to to do
not so much with the demand side
as in people wanting credit,
it seems like folks still want credit,
they still need to borrow
a lot of that money
because we are seeing credit card balances
at an all time high.
But what we are seeing is companies,
banks saying we're not
giving out as much credit.
We've seen also, we'll also get
the New York Fed household survey,
that's a quarterly report,
last time it showed all time
high record credit card debt.
So we get both of those.
But I think I wanna throw a
chart up here on your screen
that I think illustrates and really talks
about and shows what we're seeing
and why I want you to watch
out for these reports.
Now, this is the latest
Fed Senior Loan Officer
opinion survey, the SLOOS report
for us cool kids out there.
And what you see there is consistently
as we get to levels of the number of banks
saying they're raising their standards
for giving out credit or
raising their standards
for making loans, you see a recession
because banks start to get nervous.
They think, "Oh man, people
aren't gonna pay this back.
We've gotta start tightening
up and making sure
we only give credit to the
most worthy borrowers."
Well, what you see there on the right
of your screen is an unusual trend.
We've seen it pick up
and that number stay high
but not reach those 70,
75% levels like we saw
in the 2008 global financial
crisis and the Great Recession
and even in 2020 in covid.
Unusual for what you see,
usually see it pick up
and then come back down
as banks start to, that
worry starts to ease.
What you're seeing is it's staying high
and that's unusual.
And really this chart just illustrates
the unusual credit environment
that we've seen where banks really are
just raising those
standards, keeping it high,
and they're actually
turning a lot of folks away.
We saw a report actually
out from the New York Fed
just last week showing that credit
was the hardest to get in
years with fewer people
seeking out loans.
A lot of 'em reporting
that, "Hey, you know what?
I just don't think I'll get it.
I don't think the bank will give it to me
so I'm not even gonna
bother to look for it."
Important to watch
what's happening at banks
and what's happening with credit
and whether folks are able
to get the credit they want
and that they feel they need.
So that's what you're gonna
wanna watch out for this week
because I think that's
gonna tell you a big thing
about or a lot about what's
gonna happen in the future
rather than what's happening now.
Hey, listen, that's gonna do
it for us here on Market Takes.
I'm your host, Dion Rabouin,
reporter at the Wall Street Journal.
Thanks so much for tuning in
and I hope you'll be with us next time.